Well, it seems the world has become quite divided on this dress, Ma
The color you see? On the first side we have a team that says he watches black and blue - and the other side, the white and gold team
We asked Twitter followers and we got thousands of answers for both sides, white, gold, black and blue
Which is worth watching, we both saw black and blue and I think this is a big joke at first
So, how can people see it differently?
This phenomenon is called chromatography. Take this cube as an example, the middle square
Which at the top appears to be of brown color, but the square on the side appears to be
Orange color, but in fact both boxes have the same color, we assure you that we did not
Cheat or do any tricks, instead, our brains see the situation and the context, you see the shadow
It says "Oh-shadow makes objects darker color" and so on
The brain compensates and explains the box as a lighter and lighter color than it seems, until we do
Remove the shadow
Back to the dress, we have a similar case, except that the situation here is very arbitrary,
We are so close to the dress that we do not know about the surroundings
The brain has to make assumptions, people who see the dress in white have brains
The dress may be interpreted as in a room with a blue light, for example, as with a window close by
And a radiant blue sky. Logically, the white dress will be
Color blue and golden color will not really change.
On the other hand, the edification of people who see black and blue color can be interpreted
The color of the dress in artificial lighting settings - as with yellow lighting. As a result, the brain sees
The golden color as a reflection outside of the black color, believed that the blue color was not directly affected
The chances are that this picture was taken to be completely obscure on our brains, I mean
It all happens to realize each and every individual and even how and where you are viewing this picture
From a realistic point of view, this blue dress, in fact, here are some pictures of the dress
But this is a beautiful example of how our brains evolved in the interpretation of this world
Around us, even without realizing it
Do you want answers to the world's most insane phenomena? Get the book AsapSCIENCE
Go to our website asapscince.com/book - we will put the link to the description box below - and subscribe to our channel
More weekly science sections